[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Hannon heifer who is the Jacob and
Hilda blaustein professor of Judaic
Studies and professor of comparative
literature at Yale he studies the
cultural history of modern Hebrew poetry
and prose the theory of cultural and
literary critique and the history and
politics of the Hasidic tale
he has written a number of publications
on these topics in both Hebrew and
English today we'll talk with Professor
heifer about his new book Hebrew
literature and the 1948 war
essays on philology and responsibilities
welcome professor haver
thank you for having me let's start with
an overview of your book tell us about
it
basically what we have there is ten
chapters and the basic theme is trying
to understand the relationship between
there
Nach Baliye disaster Rockville is an
Arabic term okay and try to negotiate
between the literature and what happened
in Palestine during the 48 war we mean
by this I mean expulsion of 750,000
Palestinian and destroying
dozens of villages Palestine built and
the idea is to check what's going on how
literature we represent represent this
extremely extremely disaster event an
event for the platino
for the Palestinian in Palestine and
that understand what do we mean by
Hebrew literature meaning Jewish it how
the Jews are the Jews using little
doing flex to understand what went on
doing this build
okay and what led you to want to write
this book basically this filter for
variety I feel as an Israeli citizen I
have a commitment I responsibilities
what happened for today despite the fact
I'm younger but I think this is the main
main issue for many managerial Israeli
to take responsibility will happen to
the Palestinians from out by from our
side so this is the main but that is say
literature literary scholar what I want
what I want to analyze is the basic
structure literal structure like plot
characters the design of the landscape
and many many other things like this
which you used to take care or to deal
when you are trying to understand it
from a literary scholarship alright and
how are you doing
tell us about the methodology you're
using how are you doing the research for
the book first of all I chose a created
kind of selection of canonical text
Hebrew fiction Hebrew poetry the next
stage was try to locate them in this
very specific military politically and
more than this more morally situation
and then which from it's very important
the issue theory it's so complicated
talking about testimony trauma issue how
you represent violence by my literature
all this resin and of course the
question about responsibility say you
use a very important question try to
understand what is it mean right include
by writing literature you take
responsibility it's very complicated
from a theoretical point of view okay so
let's talk about that a little bit how
do you think one would take
responsibility
first of all little defined
responsibilities but where is a response
response and you answer a question you
have like a depth you have you need to
do something visibly what you see what
you know or historical materials but the
materials and so so I suppose if you
write on the send responsibility meaning
how do I say right that's right you
involve how do you involve in such a
situation from your morality if it's if
it's something that has to do with a
real an important answer problem from
ethical point of view you should
understand how what the influence on
this kind of stay it stands visibly
disaster how you deal with the language
the language of the literature is the
main issue so you argue in your book
that Hebrew literature basically fails
to take responsibility for the knock
Bach can you explain that please yes
many many examples many sorry all of
them right now sure just an example
yes displacement you are describing like
a conflict of morality ethics conflict
you have for example one was most famous
writers in this very literature some of
his how is that basically the leading
fade one
it was a story about the prisoner policy
on prison the idea what he what went
went went on so his mind is if he should
release released this Palestinian
because it's very very clear that
there's no real reason to get him okay
so what is interesting until almost the
very last moment there's no decision to
still keep him or to release release the
solution of his hell is displacement
instead of taking a real real stance
with what's going on with the prisoner
he moved he moved with his gaze to the
landscape and nothing really nothing
really is soul okay can you give us
another example yes yes for example one
one board so many yes the national poet
not an Altima is the national poet this
year here's a very favor he wrote a very
famous poem about the behavior attacking
the behavior the Israeli army during the
nut bath but if you read it carefully
it's very interesting because at the
very end you understand that for him
it's a negative exception
it's all something a regular behavior of
the armed Israeli army and this again is
quite a way that you can get you can
detach himself or any commitment take a
real responsibility of the right okay
and then the language of modern Hebrew
poetry and fiction
he'll also argue reflects the symptoms
of violence you know Israeli national
violence can you elaborate on that a
little bit yeah of course this issue of
metaphor
it's a basic figured the literal
language it's a metaphor
when a writer or one the Carter in the
India and the story
look they wreak havoc gaze there's a
very specific days that he of looking
directly to what's going on around him
but the fact is that he that what
happens there it creates like a
metaphoric structure it basically
instead of looking and seeing the
Palestinian the what's going on with the
Palestinian what you find is himself he
basically it's a moving the metaphor is
based on like connecting to field of
mimics and what he is the wisdom he
define it defines himself as someone
which is very close to the Palestinian
but the Palestinian is never has never
been existed in the story himself and
what do you ultimately conclude in your
book I
I'll use my former book to try to
formulate kind of a connection or a
narrative that goes from my first book
to the air into the new my the former
book in English was called suddenly
decide to for and basically what I did
there is trying to understand the way
that the Hebrew literature represented
the Holocaust or I prefer them the name
Hoban in a dish because this was the
language of the victim Holocaust it's
American or Israeli contemporary after
anyway the basic idea was like this
still make them
they for in the Israeli culture the main
narrative by which the culture even
policy contains contains what happened
to the 20 century meaning the Holocaust
hope and 48 war is by creating a
narrative the logical narrative from
disaster from Holocaust to Redemption I
think it's a fake one and and this is a
fake one and it basically removes any a
real a real presentation what really
happened without kind of misleading
ideology so the first one the former one
I devote a lot of energy try to
understand what happened during the
world of modern days
why if how we can define the
consciousness of the Jews immediately
after the Holocaust and you know the
problem for the Jewish people
inside and outside was to recognize the
fact the fact the Jewish people were
defeated during the boom it's very
difficult because if you have if you are
defeated it's very difficult to move
from this situation to kind of
redemptive redemptive stage so the first
book that the former book is about they
try to to understand how the major poet
the national poet ultimate basically
gave us kind of recognition recognition
of the the fact that Jewish people would
defeat Jewish people was defeated during
the war so this is the reason why it's
really why he could go forward and tell
us how what happened during the war
during the knock was I'm not saying it's
so simple so simple but this was my idea
I conclude my conclusion that the new
book is trying to understand how if you
ignore if you suppress or if you remove
more
it's much better today then ulti if a
clarity from show our redemption then we
can understand deeply what is that what
the the way we can take responsibility
of words going on now of of course 48
without courage complemented with the
language of exemption okay what are your
next steps
I've changed my field for more than 40
years even more I am writing about
modernism okay Hiba literature in
modernity modernity literature to be
honest I fed up I told to myself enough
after more than 40 years you should rest
and detach yourself of this topic now I
moved to 1890 century and my main field
of research is a Hasidic tale or let us
put it more precise way the politics of
the Hasidic way a Hasidic tale and I
enjoy okay
well we will look forward to seeing more
work from you on that topic then thank
you so much for being here with us today
thank you for more information about
Professor heifer and his research please
visit our website at Macmillan report
yale.edu be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale
you